you remember we just spoke with Alex
Lazar Jian yesterday she was covering a
fun run for her Savannah Georgia station
on Saturday and in this clip which is
now by the way been seen more than
eleven million times we see a runner
come up behind her and apparently strike
her on the bottom it seemed on purpose
in an interview with Inside Edition 43
year old Tommy Callaway says he was
trying to wave at the camera and he got
caught up in the moment
there was a misjudge in character and
decision-making I touched her back I did
not know exactly where a touched her
I did not see her facial reaction as I
just kept on running and if I did see
her facial reaction I would have been
embarrassed
I'd have been felt ashamed and I were to
stop turn around and went back and
apologize to her as rgn told us
yesterday that she felt Calaway and her
words just helped himself to part of her
body that she was embarrassed and that
she was hurt and she was ashamed she's
filed a police report and she tells us
she's not sure of her next step you can
tell she's clearly startled and caught
off guard by that much I'm not sure I
heard an apology in that statement yes
he was if I'd seen her facial reaction I
would have apologized now that you have
seen her reaction along with 11 other
embarrassed by it you know he would have
been ashamed embarrassed he said yeah
and he's got two daughters he also
thought about that something yeah yeah